[Applaudissements]
donner son sang allait donner le vôtre
vous êtes bons apôtres
monsieur le président est-ce que c'est
vers vous disent quelque chose qui c'est
qui a écrit ça déjà boris vian away dans
les années 50 alors que l'armée
française était très engagé dans la
guerre d'indochine est la guerre
d'algérie
boris vian avait écrit cette chanson et
qu'elle avait un petit peu déstabilisé
le pouvoir en place
parce que tout bonnement elle a été
interdite par l'état français et aussi
probablement que cette chanson a pu
raccourcir la guerre d'algérie d'à peu
près deux ans
[Musique]
monsieur le président je vous fais une
lettre que vous lirez peut-être vent si
vous avez le temps je viens de recevoir
mes papiers militaires pour partir à la
guerre avant mercredi soir
monsieur le président je ne veux pas
l'affairé
je ne suis pas sûr que pour tuer des
pauvres gens
c'est pas pour vous fâcher
il faut que je vous dise
ma décision est prise je m'en vais
déserté
depuis que je suis né j'ai vu mourir mon
père
j'ai vu partir mes frères et blu ray mes
enfants ma mère a tant souffert
elle est dedans ça tombe
est ce que des bombes et se moque des
verts
quand j'étais en prison
on m'a volé ma femme on m'a volé mon âme
et tout mon chêne passé
[Musique]
demain de bon matin je fermerai ma porte
au nez des années morte
j'irai sur les chemins je mendie ma vie
sur les routes de france de bretagne en
provence et je disais aux gens
refusaient d'obéir refusé de la faire
n'allez pas ça la guerre refusaient de
partir s'il fonde et son sang allait
donner le vaudreuil vous êtes mon
encontre
monsieur le président si vous me
poursuivait
prévenez vos gendarmes pour que je
n'aurais pas d'âme et qu'ils pourront
tirer
[Musique]
une autre chanson à peu près à la même
époque fait le même effet interdiction
par l'état français
qu'est ce que c'est cette chanson c'est
quand
quand un soldat écrite par francis
lemarque et chantée par yves montand
fleurot fleur au fusil tambour battant
il va il a 20 ans un choeur damman qui
bat un adjudant pour surveiller ses
pains et son barda contre ses flancs qui
bat quentin soldats s'en va-t-en guerre
il a dans sa musette son bâton maja
quand un soldat revient de guerre est là
dans sa musette un peu de linge sale
partir pour mourir un peu à la guerre à
la guerre
reut c'est un drôle de petit jeu qui ne
va guère aux amoureux pourtant c'est
presque toujours quand revient l'été
qu'il faut son année le ciel regarde
partir ceux qui vont mourir au pas
cadencé les hommes il en vaut toujours
carragher car la guerre se fout des
serments d'amour elle même gueule son du
tambour
quand un soda 120 en guerre il a des tas
de chansons et des fleurs sous ses parts
quand un soldat revient de guerre il a
simplement eu de la chance et puis voilà
simplement eu de la veine et puis voilà
simplement eu l'avènement puis voilà
alors des chansons interdites il y en a
depuis longtemps
même à l'époque médiévale les
mercenaires suisses qui étaient des
combattants aguerris était engagé chez
les rois francs et avec l'interdiction
de chanter une certaine chanson qui leur
rappelait beaucoup trop leur pays natal
parce qu'après il se mettait il se
rappelle tellement de la suisse qu'elle
se mettait à pleurer ils déposaient les
armes et même des fois il naquit rentrer
à la maison a carrément donc
interdiction de chanter cette chanson
sous peine de mort
et puis aujourd'hui et ben moi
j'aimerais rush hanter cette chanson et
en lui donnant un autre regard un
peut-être un nouveau regard parce que
c'est une chanson qui traite de la
traite des vaches et j'aimerais rendre
un hommage à toutes ces vaches que qu'on
exploite en fait aujourd'hui tous les
jours des veaux qui sont séparés dès la
naissance dans des petits enclos qui
peuvent presque pas bougé alors avant en
chanter cette chanson par amour des
vaches alors qu'est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui l'amour des vaches
si ce n'est de les exploiter tous les
jours donc repenser le pouvoir c'est
aussi repenser le pouvoir qu'on exerce
sur les animaux sur la nature et sur
notre écosystème
[Applaudissements]
les armaillis des clodettes de vent dans
ce solo va à
mais pas
oh
à eau
aulas
les eaux
oba lots
au bas mot
alors
allez
on vit des temps bien ce n'est le seul
modèle est une année à trets déjà ce
titre you love jarriot de justice are
you yet en radio néo pro
aulas
les eaux
au bas mot
aubin
[Musique]
là
alé lô
les channel va le premier relais total
elle va laden
[Musique]
les eaux
bat lyon
ou pas
là
allure
bah bah ouais
l'agent
les eaux
lyon
pas
oh
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
certaines chansons n'ont pas été
interdites
peut-être parce qu'elles sont trop
jeunes parce qu'elles sont pas assez
connus quoi qu'il en soit c'est nous qui
les avons écrite
[Musique]
alors repenser le pouvoir ça peut se
faire mais sans changement
il n'y a pas grand chose
[Musique]
le temps coule dans la passoire de
l'existence noyé dans la foule
4e on danse
on pressent n'écrase torche rien dans la
tête tout dans la manche
[Musique]
à tombeau ouvert on ne voit pas ses
dires les frontières se faire et les
murs se construire au saut de rennes
éclats de rire
semaine
moi je me demande ce qui nous fait tenir
[Musique]
savamment
t
[Musique]
le temps coule dans la passoire de
l'existant se noyait dans la faune de la
quatre pattes
on pense
c
[Musique]
pour
nos poison nos prisons nous désire
ce que l'on possède tout ce qui nous
pose 7
tout va trop vite à quoi bon courir et
cette ceinture de dynamite à quoi fait
elle servira des morceaux de rêve
éclats de rire parfois je me demande
comment ça va finir
m
[Musique]
le temps coule dans la passoire de
l'existence noyé dans la foule à quatre
pattes on danse on danse
[Musique]
de vendre pas tourner la tête c'est nous
le changement il suffit d'être honnête
quoi
un peu plus loin que tu as fait même le
monde est en mouvement
il arrive en tempête
les rois les tyrans des prophètes
hébreux de nos carcans à nous la
conquête et bien
des quatre coins de la planète
[Musique]
l'avenir maintenant c'est de toi qui
étais pas
[Musique]
c
oui
sommeil
[Musique]
savon
un pas
[Musique]
sans martijn
à
[Musique]
sander
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]